[Musique]
en jeu un animateur un chroniqueur un
technicien et deux invités
bienvenue sur radio en ouailles ce média
éphémère c'est le fruit d'une formation
web radio destinée aux professionnels de
l'enseignement comme alex qui a pour
projet de créer un média scolaire au
lycée professionnel de chateauboeuf
cette webradio en fait pour vous est ce
que ça représente un plus pour trait
tablissements ah oui tout à fait mais
pour permettre aux élèves de maîtriser
l'outil informatique et puis de
travailler sous les réseaux notamment
mettre en place un conducteur réalisé
une interview animer une émission lors
de cette formation de deux demi-journées
la théorie et la pratique webradio sont
au centre de l'apprentissage
c'est quand même un outil exigeant au
niveau de la technique donc pouvoir
utiliser une table de mixage gérer les
micros être capable de chercher un
générique ou un jingle organisé par
canopée le réseau de création et
d'accompagnement pédagogique
cet atelier s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'éducation aux médias à l'école quand
un chef d'établissement ou un inspecteur
pour la décision de mettre une web radio
dans l'établissement dans la
circonscription c'est c'est toujours
intéressant que des enseignants soient
formés et donc par voie de conséquence
qu'il y ait des élèves qu'ils soient
sensibilisés dans un établissement où
l'école pour pouvoir faire travailler
autour de ce média pour créer une web
radio dans un établissement scolaire il
faut compter environ 2000 euros
mais aujourd'hui un simple téléphone et
des logiciels gratuits peuvent déjà aidé
à démarrer